[Musique]
je lis le texte qui a été présentée afin
qu'ils étaient demandés et écrit par la
famille ou par l'ami qui envoie ce
message je chante un bon anniversaire je
fait souffler la bougie virtuelle et je
chante une chanson de mon répertoire qui
a été choisi au répertoire ça va de
paire silva les fables aux roses
blanches jusqu'à satisfaction des stones
voilà en passant par les rita mitsouko
joe dassin et puis des chansons de
guinguette et je ressens plus actuelle
[Musique]
on n'aime pas beaucoup ce genre de haut
quand on est artiste mais j'ai souhaité
mettre une participation à hauteur d'un
joli bouquet de fleurs qui est qu'en
général on livre alors au lieu de le
livrer un bouquet de fleurs eh bien on
me renvoie sur les autres internet pour
rhabiller du sourire joyeuse à l'hiver
joyeux anniversaire
joyeuse arrivée 68 fin de l'hiver
à la une à la deux et la trois